the calm of the old city in the middle
of the night shifted to the chaos of an
attack on sunday
police say a man ambushed a bus in a
parking lot near the western wall at
about 1 30 in the morning two people
outside i see
falling
two inside
it was
bleeding
the driver says he tried to pull away
but was unable to because the wheelchair
ramp was lowered
two of the wounded are in a serious
condition a pregnant woman in her 30s
with an abdominal injury is still in the
operating room a very complex injury and
a man in his 60s with injuries to the
neck and head also a gunshot wound and
is now in the intensive care unit
a six hour manhunt followed police
cordoned off the area set up checkpoints
to search people and cars and raided
homes in silwan the palestinian
neighborhood has previously been the
site of violent protests against illegal
demolitions of homes with allegations
that the israelis are pushing out
families police say a 24-year-old
palestinian man eventually turned
himself in and confessed
this is a lone attacker a resident of
the city with a criminal record
there is one conclusion from this event
as from the previous events whoever
harms the citizens of israel will have
nowhere to run we will hunt them down
and we will deal with them with full
force of the law
hamas which controls the gaza strip and
the armed group palestinian islamic she
had praised the attack saying it's a
continuation of palestinian resistance
to the israeli occupation the attack
happened one week after egypt negotiated
a ceasefire between israel and the
islamic jihad on august 5th the israeli
military launched a three-day operation
against the group in gaza killing nearly
50 palestinians including 17 children
there have been concerns the cease-fire
would collapse because islamic jihad is
lobbying for the release of two
prisoners israeli interim prime minister
yair lapid promised to restore calm and
security to jerusalem sunday's attack is
a reminder that it's virtually
impossible to ensure that it will last
natasha name al jazeera occupied east
jerusalem